be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
you know I almost completely forgot
about chaos war if I'm being honest with
you guys I almost completely and totally
forgot about this story I was so looking
forward to like house like the
conclusion of how some powers of X I
didn't even think about I was just like
yeah man like x-men stuff cool all right
moving on and then I was I was looking
and I was like because I usually do a
week a weekly recap kind of going
through the videos that I've done to
make sure I don't really have any loose
ends and I was like oh we never finished
chaos war so chaos war the conclusion
basically Hercules becomes like the most
powerful God ever it's interesting right
because in the last video we had like
basically the the chaos King me Kobashi
essentially just kind of like crushing
the entirety of the godly Pantheon right
like basically everyone that the chaos
king is face off against he's either
ensnared or destroyed right and when I
say and snared I mean brought them under
his control so that they become his
servants and this includes like the
entire multiverse right it's one of the
things Amadeus Cho says is that like the
chaos King has basically removed or
consumed 98% of the multiverse so it's
not just the main Marvel Universe right
now here's one of the questions people
are gonna ask where's the Living
Tribunal if a single being comes into
the in in into this story like basically
comes out of his dimension and starts
just like annihilating the entirety of
the multiverse and consumes 98% of it
then where's the Living Tribunal
where's the tribunal like we have no
idea what the Living Tribunal is doing
but it's not here and that's the reason
why is because if the tribunal showed up
in this story and you have to imagine
the chaos king is an aspect of the
cosmic entity oblivion right and if you
go when you look at the cosmic order in
terms of how Marvel's depicted it over
the years the like oblivion is
essentially equal to eternity and if
that's the case and then oblivion itself
is weaker than the Living Tribunal in
which case the chaos scheme will be
weaker than the Living Tribunal so the
tribunal would show up it in the
conflict like that and they would
basically be over in the blink of an eye
and so you couldn't tell a story off of
that right especially if it involves a
character like Hercules and so that's
why the tribunals not here is because
the story needs to be told and that
story couldn't be told if they if the if
the Living Tribunal showed up so what
this does is it basically picks up with
Athena meeting with the chaos scheme now
we ended the last video on that and in
fact it was just like a massive
underwhelming cliffhanger and you'd be
right if you were just like that that
like the ending of that video sucks it
does because the end of aiming of that
story sucks because chaos war is okay
but it's not the greatest story ever but
the cool thing about this is that Athena
as one of the Greek gods to kind of look
down on humanity and looked at the rest
of the world was going in right and was
basically like so the world kind of
sucks now and
it's it's corrupt and it's screwed up so
what we need to do is basically
annihilate everything and start anew and
that's why she allied herself with with
the chaos King because pretty much
everything that unfolded the way that it
had had been done by virtue of Athena
herself right it's kind of like the
guiding hand of the chaos King because
the chaos King is a force of nature is
really what he is right I mean he's an
aspect of oblivion which means he's just
an idea he's a concept that's out there
right it's like it's like a hurricane
but a hurricane just moves in in a
particular direction and whatever
happens to be in its path is what gets
consumed or destroyed or what-have-you
the question is what if you could guide
that hurricane towards particular
destinations that's kind of what Athena
did she guided this sort of hurricane of
the chaos king and said go here and then
go there and then take those guys out
and those guys out and so on and so
forth which really kind of gives us a
pretty good understanding of her role
within Marvel right because she's the
goddess of wisdom and in Greek mythology
and so because that she had basically
guide in his hand and she knew what was
going to happen here she knew that at
the end of all this you know when her
role was done and she was no longer
needed by the chaos king that he would
destroy her but notice this her response
to this is yes like given your ability
to go through and inflict all this
destruction and to do everything you
want to do and return all of reality
back to a primordial void that
eventually life will reform again this
primordial void will basically begin to
sort of coalesce so on so forth energy
will basically erupt and all of the
existence will come back into play again
and then when that happens life will
begin anew and it'll have the chance to
do it again quote-unquote the right time
right so Athena's ideology here is I
along side everybody else will die and
be reborn you however will remain in the
primordial void or whatever happens to
you happens to you whatever the case is
but is this kind of idea that she's
willing to sacrifice her life for what
she believes to be a greater cause and
it's kind of interesting here because in
response to that the chaos came
basically seizes control of her and
forces her to become his servant because
up to this point that was never the case
she worked with him willingly so what
this does is it basically picks up with
Hercules meeting with essentially what's
left of the primordial gods that exist
in you know throughout the Marvel
Universe released the Marvel multiverse
to be honest if your accounting other
dimensions and so on and so forth those
survivors who have fled to this location
and what's going on here is really just
kind of like a moment of respite right
it's a chance to say goodbye all these
gods here are basically just bent over
and kiss their backsides goodbye and
that's really where things are at the
moment because you're talking about a
singular being who's gone throughout the
entirety of the multiverse eradicated
98% of it and those who he didn't kill
he basically bent to his whim there
really
seems to be no way to win here and in
fact like Galactus is one of the only
cosmic entities left now this is one of
the things you also kind of have to bear
in mind here is the nature of the cosmic
entities right because people would ask
the question well what about what about
entities like infinity or what about
entities like yelling or something like
that so cosmic entities really kind of
exist in like two forms right you have
their real form for lack of a better
word and then you have the form that you
see right so like when eternity shows up
or something like that that's the form
that you see their real form is that
they're they don't really have a
physical form right later they're an
ideology right so it's like show me the
physical form of the thought in your
head that says I need to go to the
grocery store it's an abstract concept
they go to anthropomorphize the
dimension of manifestations when they
want to get a true form but by and large
are just an ideology if eternity in a
particular universe represents
everything that makes up that universe
and then that universe ceases to be then
so would that version of eternity right
infinity all those different iterations
here just like Galactus are a little
different because he doesn't really
represent an ideology he does to a
degree but he is actually a beam but if
he doesn't have like an energy physical
form he doesn't go somewhere in uniform
he actually has it's basically like a
giant a mass of energy and like
basically this kind of suit that travels
around and consumes worlds and different
things like that but it gets kind of
interesting it's kind of wonky when you
get to the nature of cosmic entities and
and so on and so forth but yeah that's
the answer why you don't really see the
cosmic entities here is he you know
you're not gonna see him from a
different universe because the universe
has been wiped out and they cease to
exist now as for for Hercules being here
and basically talking to these various
you know gods who were here almost
immediately after he arrives he's
attacked by Athena and the funny thing
about this is that Athena trying to take
him out at the same time that like the
negative zone is basically invading the
entirety of the universe all of whom
were essentially swearing Failte in some
former fashion to a chaos king as well
as really is kind of like everything
sort of coming to an end everything sort
of winding down
is it Athena's ideology when she is
initially set loose the circumstance
that would have Amadeus Cho be the one
who would save the multiverse instead of
Amadeus Cho going to this pocket bubble
that Hera had basically created this
kind of pocket universe that existed
outside of all the entirety of the
multiverse is that it was designed to
keep Hercules safe right because Athena
knew what was gonna come she's like
these are all the things that I'm
planning these are all the things that
I'm working on I've wanted to keep
Hercules alive but then it was kind of a
really sort of a screwed up scenario
when Amadeus Cho having you know free
will and doing what is it he can
ultimately went and brought Hercules
back that was not supposed to happen as
that's why things are kind of running a
lie a little bit at the moment is
because things you know as far as is the
thiness plans go they're supposed to go
off without a hitch and the result is
that for the most part Hercules is kind
of an idiot and so even though he's
doing the right thing and he's trying to
save the world he's kind of blundering
his way through it and sort of screwing
things up at the same time but the big
moment with all of this stuff though the
really huge moment here is kind of this
revelation of Gaia now when it comes to
the characters and Marvel Comics if you
go back and you read the old stories
from from all like the old really like
the Old Forest stories by Walt Simonson
the old Avenger stories by Roy Thomas
what you got here was this kind of
explanation of how the universe and that
gods tie into it right the funny thing
is that if you go in you read Walt
Simonson story you get one explanation
about how everything came into existence
and even if you go read tales of Asgard
by Jack Kirby you get a different
explanation if you read some of the
Avengers stories a deal with the origins
of the universe by Roy Thomas you get
one explanation right so different
stories all sort of iterated in
different ways this is despite the fact
that Greg Pak is pitching this to us as
an absolute it is only really one of
multiple iterations of how all things
came into existence right so kind of
take this with a grain of salt here
but what Gaius says is that she's
basically the mother of all gods in
existence initially Gaia existed before
there ever was a universe right she was
kind of a sister or a companion of sorts
to oblivion
that's not explicitly stated so I
wouldn't run with that but the idea was
that when when the universe came into
existence which is to say this space
that all the planets and solar systems
would occupy it was Gaia who basically
gave birth to it all and again it's just
one of many interpretations of the
origin of the universe
none of these are an absolute right
there is no absolute explanation on the
origin of the universe but the big thing
here is that because of the the nature
of the story and the way it's being told
if Gaia is the mother of all gods that
it means that essentially she can amp up
the powers of Hercules and where the
earth itself is quite literally being
torn apart by chaos he himself kind of
siphoning off all these energies and so
on and so forth ultimately what ends up
happening is Gaia basically boosts up
the power of Hercules and then says now
you are the god of gods which means you
have to go forward accordingly and it's
kind of a funny thing because what she
says here is the human side of you will
want to save everyone the human side of
you will want to say everybody needs to
be saved everybody needs to be alive but
the reality is you can't save everyone
more than those you lose but move
forward accordingly and it's kind of
interesting because it's something that
Hercules really initially seems to
disagree with but the way the greg pack
does it it's almost sort of a
explanation of why the gods are the way
they are right like why are the
Olympian gods the way they are and why
are the Norse gods the way they are you
know Odin and Thor and all those guys
now if you don't really know the history
of Marvel you would look at that and say
well it's because they're dicks but the
reality is that Odin and all his guys
and Zeus and all his guys and all the
various gods who kind of exists out
there the sky fathers their hands off
humanity because they were instructed to
do so right like in the early days when
Celestials showed up on earth and they
started meddling in the genes of man
gods had it had a constant ongoing
relationship with humanity right that's
one of the reasons why when you look at
the history of Marvel people like
worship gods all the time and for them
they were an absolute truth because they
were at the time and the issue is that
because there was so much meddling going
on by the gods in the affairs of mortal
men Celestials didn't want that and the
result was that they showed up and they
said if you guys continue to meddle in
the affairs of Man will destroy you all
and so that that basically kind of
created a wall between Odin and his ilk
and and Zeus and his ilk and all the
other sky followers that you see which
is why you don't see them acting all
that often but the overall gist here is
that with Hercules getting this massive
power up from Gaia he is exceedingly
powerful now with him facing off against
the chaos king one of the funny things
about this is that when you look at
stories like this right where it shows
Hercules and the chaos came fighting
each other and the earth just sitting
there a lot of times those are done as a
way to kind of show us how extreme this
situation is but it's not meant to be
taken literally in this story it is
right like they're literally bigger than
the world and they're literally fighting
outside of the earth it's kind of cool
but all this really sort of comes down
to amedeo right because with Galactus
working alongside Cho and with Cho's
idea being hey look there was this
pocket reality that existed outside of
all space and time that Hera created to
lock hercules away the initial response
of Galactus and show is okay we could
take everybody in humanity and we can
send them there and it's kind of a cool
thing because what Galactus is doing is
building one of his world engines of
sorts but actually finding a way to open
this portal which he successfully does
and where the portals open and where he
tells Amadeus Cho get all your people in
there Cho's starts calculating all these
possibilities and starts to realize that
he can't save every right there like for
all the people that he'll save millions
are going to die you can't save everyone
all the time some folks just aren't
gonna make it and the inability to grasp
that reality I think is what
differentiates people who wish the world
could be a certain way versus people who
understand the reality of the world the
way it is right you know living in a
realistic world versus living in a
fantasy land and so it's kind of cool
because with Amadeus Cho sort of
calculating all these is like
there's no way to save all of humanity
by wishing them all to a different
location but then there is an idea that
suddenly occurs to him by virtue of
Hercules and it's Hercules just saying
like like you can't you know we can't
let it in this way and that's when it
dawns on Amadeus Cho bring the chaos
came down here as fast as you can like
get him down to earth which of course
Hercules is able to do and when that
happens you have basically the God Squad
right so like Thor and all these seven
characters who all show up and they
basically all start launching an attack
that's not really designed to defeat the
chaos king so much as distract him and
keep him slightly weakened and what it
does is it allows Hercules with a chaos
king in his weakened form to grab him
and then throw him into the void
basically that that place that exists
outside of all space and time that Hera
had created that's where he resides and
everything to sort of devolves back down
into that space the problem with this is
that where the chaos king is technically
destroyed it's like the Langille ears
from from from Stephen Kings from
Stephen King's book right like
everything is pretty much consumed
there's really nothing they can do here
I mean yeah they saved all of creation
but there's like huge holes huge gaping
holes in the multiverse right I mean
like 98% of it's gone as it was kind of
crazy here because at that point Athena
then basically approaches Hercules and
says hey look you can recreate
everything you can destroy everything
wipe everything out and then let life
begin again and then basically fulfill
my plan which of course in the eyes of
Hercules is nonsense as it's kind of
intriguing here because you can make an
argument on both sides right I mean you
I could make an argument for Hercules
and say okay so Hercules is wanting to
follow the role of the traditional hero
everybody deserves a chance to continue
living on but here's the reality if
people wanted to correct their lives
they would have done it by now and if
they don't want to then is Athena wrong
by saying the world is screwed up and
corrupt and if she's right about that
then maybe it is in the best interest of
all things in reality to wipe it all out
and to basically start anew right so to
cleanse it all and start new but the
funny thing is that ultimately Hercules
ends up coming out on top and saying no
we are not going to do that right we're
not going to wipe out most of this
universe right here's kind of a funny
thing is how did the theme to come back
I don't know but the fact remains though
basically he's like we're gonna do what
heroes are supposed to do which is
protect those and lead those into a
better tomorrow so what he does is he
basically disperses all this power that
he has and recreates the entirety of
reality right like croute recreates the
entirety of the multiverse and restores
everything back to the way it was now
here's the problem with this right
here's the biggest problem with this and
this was the big problem with Marvel
between 2003 2004 running up to about
2012 right
a lot of events that took place where
even if it wasn't on like a great big
huge multiversal scale and there were a
lot of events that took place whereby
everything could have been destroyed and
it kind of was and then ultimately set
back to the way it was before all this
kicked off in the first place and it's
kind of like that's interesting and I
get that but the issue with stories like
this is it doesn't matter right like
that the story doesn't have any
significance here aside from maybe a
couple of a couple of characters that
were affected because literally like
Thor ends up going to Olympus and it's
like okay so like I guess I'll take up
residence for Zeus and like that's
basically it right like the incredible
Hercules story ends there's there's no
real impact to this right it's kind of
like okay so basically there's this guy
out there who's an aspect of one of the
most powerful cosmic entities in
existence and this guy's name is a chaos
king and the chaos king wants to return
everything to the void and then in the
process of doing it wipes out pretty
much everything that he comes across in
order to achieve this goal at the end of
the day it's all basically stopped by by
a young kid named Amadeus Cho who thinks
of this one scenario there basically is
only really able to be maintained by the
power of Hercules and so once the chaos
king is totally destroyed
Hercules recreate everything and it goes
right back to the way it was before
what's the aftermath here what's the
benefit to a story like this and that's
why I'm not necessarily against you know
multiverse shattering stories I'm not
necessarily against the notion of like
all things are going to end and end that
kind of stuff so long as it has a
purpose afterwards right so long as I
feel rewarded for having been part of it
you know it's it's kind of a cool thing
the only exception to that is if you're
looking at stories at least if I'm
looking at stories like spider-verse
right because technically the whole of
spider-verse if you're reading
spider-man because people ask me all the
time I want to get sort of a Spider Man
where do I start start with a Dan slash
spider-man Big Time but once you get to
superior spider-man the whole entire
spider-verse event takes place between
like superior spider-man issues 21 and
22 it's just it's like that right I mean
it just happens it happens you know in
between those two issues but the cool
thing is that what came out of it was
one like you got to see this this is
kind of wrapping up plot threads with
like more Lund and the inheritors and so
on and so forth and - you could have
built on top of that and come back where
that later on the chaos games gone he's
destroyed he doesn't exist anymore so
there's no bringing him back right I
mean there's no returning that guy back
here and kind of kicking it off from
there so it's kind of an interesting
story but not without its problems not
without its its its criticisms but yeah
if you guys are new here to come as
explain make sure you all hit the sub
button to become part of the rod core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
purse
[Applause]
[Music]